[Musique]
le sport fait partie de l'ADN du
militaire pour le fantassin l'aviateur
ou encore le marin l'entraînement
physique est indissociable de la
préparation au combat il est aussi un
formidable outil de cohésion
[Musique]
du parcours d'obstacle aux premières
marches des podiums des techniques de
corps-à-corps à la reconstruction pomme
psychique physique des blessés de guerre
le sport est omniprésent dans les armées
comment les militaires se préparent-ils
physiquement pour être opérationnel
quels sont leur interactions avec le
sport de haut niveau le journal de la
défense vous propose de partir à la
rencontre de ces hommes et ses femmes
qui incarne les différentes facettes du
sport militaire
[Musique]
le sport fait partie du quotidien du
soldat loin d'être à loisir il est avant
tout une nécessité
avec des engagements opérationnels de
plus en plus exigeants physiquesment et
psychologiquement maintenir une bonne
condition physique est indispensable
pour le militaire
dans le statut du militaire il est
obligatoire que effectivement chaque
militaire et une condition physique qui
lui permettre d'être apte au combat
c'est-à-dire la projection
opérationnelle donc les armans intégrés
ce dispositif depuis des années le
règlementé de sorte que chaque année
tout militaire quel que soit son genre
fait l'objet d'une évaluation physique
d'un contrôle physique de la préparation
militaire
l'héritier d'une non tradition sportive
militaire le Centre national des sports
de la défense mène la politique
ministérielle des sports et répond aux
enjeux
il veille tout particulièrement à la
préparation physique du combattant je
pourrais même pas dire ce que je vais
pas te prendre pour cela il s'appuie sur
un réseau de spécialistes déployés dans
les unités et services des armées les
moniteurs et instructeurs de
l'entraînement physique militaire et
sportif
dans chaque unité ils appliquent un
programme adapté au milieu et conditions
d'emploi des militaires axé sur la
guérissement
[Musique]
être physiquement fort pour l'être aussi
moralement c'est l'objectif de la
préparation physique et mentale du
combattant organiser tout au long de
l'année par la Marine nationale à Toulon
nous rejoignons l'équipage de la frégate
aconit qui s'apprête à suivre une de ses
préparations
la préparation physique et mentale du
combattant c'est un stage
d'aguerissement durant lequel on
sollicite l'équipage sur une période de
36 heures de façon à les mettre en
situation d'inconfort dans un cadre
sécurisé
alors sont des exercices d'aguerissement
à dominante physique principalement mais
qui avec le cumul vont aboutir sur une
phase mentale
on les évalue sur des critères très
simples sur la gestion du stress de la
fatigue sur la façon de faire remonter
les informations de ce comporter sur le
terrain et de voir si les consignes sont
respectées par rapport à cet état de
fatigue à cet état de stress
allez
[Musique]
salut
pour un équipage
c'est nous mettre dans les conditions
d'un confort pour nous permettre d'être
prêt à
résister à n'importe quel événement qui
soit en mer ou faire une dernière et
chaque nouvelle compte parce que si un
Cara de son truc derrière tout le monde
est pénalisé et le but c'est pas de
faire en sorte que tout le monde soit
contre celui karaté au contraire c'est
bien de dire parce que ça peut arriver
n'importe lequel c'est jamais le même
donc le but c'est bien de pouvoir
trouver la solution trouver la force en
équipage voilà je vous laisse
[Musique]
abandonnons tout long pour le terrain
d'entraînement de Mailly le camp dans
l'Aube où nous retrouvons une unité du
cinquième régiment de dragon
dans quelques semaines ils seront
déployés sur l'opération sentinelle
opération de lutte contre le terrorisme
sur le territoire national
de la matinée séance Dior ou technique
d'intervention opérationnelle rapprochée
[Musique]
on utilise des techniques donc de
palpation de sécurité parce que nous
contrairement aux forces de l'ordre on
n'a pas le droit de faire des fouilles
donc juste une palpation de sécurité
pour être sûr que l'individu n'a rien
dangereux sur lui on pose aussi des
entraves des menottes on a des modules
donc avec le bâton de défense
télescopique pour aussi se défendre
contre les armes blanches et une séance
de Dior c'est assez éprouvant sur le
plan physique et aussi moral parfois on
sort d'une séance de tueur normalement
l'esquiver
1 2 3
au dessus de nos têtes d'autres
militaires s'aguérissent ce sont les
pilotes de la Patrouille de France tous
sont des pilotes expérimentés
que ce soit lors d'un vol de 8h sur des
théâtres d'opération ou comme ici pour
voler en patrouille serré à 8 avions et
à des vitesses allant jusqu'à 800 km/h
la préparation physique et mentale des
pilotes de chasse et vital
[Musique]
tous les pilotes suivent un entraînement
sportif pour être à réaliser leur
mission ses ambassadeurs de l'Armée de
l'Air bénéficient quant à eux d'une
préparation physique très spécifique
[Musique]
on a beaucoup de chance ici l'armée de
l'air bien à notre disposition des
moyens énormes que ce soit en matériel
ou en personnel comme ici avec un
moniteur de sport qui nous est attitré
pendant toute l'année et qui nous suit
qui nous connaît extrêmement bien et qui
va pouvoir nous proposer des séances
adaptées pour qu'on soit au top en début
de saison lors de ses vols en patrouille
les pilotes peuvent subir jusqu'à 7 g
soit sept fois le poids de leur corps
de précision donc tout ça ça demande de
la concentration de l'énergie physique
et donc c'est pour ça que ici en sport
on va travailler ça le matin et le soir
environ 7 heures par semaine la pratique
de l'activité physique elle a pas trop
de France en saison hivernale dans un
premier temps elle nous aide pas
récupéré elle nous fatigue plus
puisqu'on va tout mener de front on va
on va commencer les premiers vols à 8
qui sont énergivores on va attaquer la
préparation physique et donc tout ça ça
va ça va nous consommer de l'énergie à
terme ça doit nous permettre d'en sauver
parce qu'on a on aura un niveau et une
capacité physique supérieure à celle du
départ
ramène encore plus ici et je ramène au
vraiment doucement bras tendu et
l'entraînement qui subissent le volume
horaire c'est vraiment un polymore de
sportif de niveau il faut avoir une
bonne préparation sur les muscles
profonds ce qu'on appelle les muscles
posturaux parce que au sein de l'avion
ils ont parfois même souvent et ben des
postures inappropriées inhabituelles et
donc il faut bosser tous ces muscles là
afin qu'ils puissent être prêts à avoir
la tête tournée pendant un long moment à
subir au niveau de la colonne vertébrale
et bah des mouvements qui sont pas
ordinaires et donc on a un gros travail
sur sur la partie musculaire en plus
avec la PAF c'est important d'avoir une
grosse cohésion d'équipe pendant toute
l'année toute la saison ensemble où la
fatigue va être au rendez-vous ou c'est
parfois même souvent intense et donc on
a une grosse partie disons collective où
on va essayer de de faire monter le
groupe vers le haut et donc de les
préparer à vivre ensemble
un entraînement physique et mental
exigeant que pratique également
l'ensemble des pilotes de chasse pour
que leurs organismes soient prêts à
supporter les conditions extrêmes de
leur vol quelle que soit leur mission
[Musique]
mais la meilleure préparation physique
et mentale ne constitue pas une garantie
à 100% contre la blessure pour les
militaires le risque est toujours
présent des blessures visibles ou
invisibles qu'il faut savoir ensuite
réparer
l'engagement du militaire
implique forcément une notion de risque
qui est très élevée et lorsque ce risque
se traduit en blessure physique ou
psychique il est de devoir désormais de
l'institution en premier lieu puis
ensuite de la nation de prendre en
compte les conséquences de ce risque
mais de les prendre en compte à la fois
pour le blesser mais également pour sa
famille nous avons créé aujourd'hui à
dispositif intégré cohérent avec une
gouvernance partagée qui aboutit à
proposer à l'ensemble de nos blessés
tout un parcours
logique qui va du sport pour se
reconstruire c'est-à-dire globalement le
loisir jusqu'à la haute performance
aujourd'hui très concrètement ce sont
600 militaires provenant de toutes les
armées la voirie qui bénéficie de
soutien ces colossal alors qu'ils à
peine 5 ans il y en avait 10 fois moins
en repoussant les barrières du handicap
le sport contribue à la reconstruction
physique et mentale des blessés c'est un
moyen de leur redonner confiance en eux
et de rendre possible ce que l'on
croyait devenu irréalisable
c'est l'histoire de Cédric blessé
plusieurs fois en opération
le sport pour moi a été une échappatoire
quand j'étais déjà en opération pour
pouvoir en fait
revivre et me sentir vivre et surtout
pouvoir me défouler et évacuer un petit
peu cette pression et ce mal-être que
j'avais et aujourd'hui au quotidien ça
me permet de pouvoir m'évader et surtout
de pouvoir aérer mon esprit ce qui me
permet voilà entre les soins que je suis
avec les psychologues les médecins plus
le sport c'est un équilibre avec aussi
la famille c'est très important donc on
va dire que ça fait un triangle travail
sport famille et ce triangle en fait ça
fait trois piliers on arrive à s'en
sortir aujourd'hui des structures sont
faites pour nous pour les blesser
n'importe quelle pathologie peut avoir
accès à ce genre de stage de
reconstruction et aujourd'hui il faut
qu'on en faut qu'on en profite faut
qu'on en profite surtout pour notre
bien-être pour avoir un équilibre
familial et au niveau du travail
Thomas devenu unijambiste après un
accident de la route hors service la
pratique sportive lui a redonné
confiance en lui
[Musique]
derrière
juste en bas comme ça allez on arrache
tout
ma reconstruction d'abord
psychologiquement de revoir du monde
d'être confronté aussi aux autres au
regard des autres mais aussi ben dans le
challenge on se dépassant et ensuite
forcément c'est physiquement pour être
stable avec une jambe en moins faut se
muscler certaines parties il faut
remuscler d'autres qui sont un peu moins
sollicités pour garder une stabilité et
éviter tout ce qui est douleur ou de
forcer sur l'autre membre en participant
à un des stages du Centre national des
sports de la défense dédié aux blessés
Thomas est approché par des moniteurs de
sport qui lui propose alors plusieurs
activités adaptées à son handicap
l'occasion pour lui de découvrir des
sports qu'il n'avaient jamais encore
pratiqué j'ai pu faire du surf et de la
pirogue donc c'est pareil du surf j'en
avais jamais fait et en fait je me suis
dit bon ben je me mettrai jamais debout
voilà donc j'ai eu une prothèse qui
pouvait aller dans l'eau donc j'ai pu
travailler
sur sur une semaine m'entraîner et
réussir à faire à faire du surf donc
voilà ça redonne confiance en soi et
puis on se dit mais en fait c'est comme
pour tous les autres sports que j'ai pu
réessayer ou découvrir en fait il y a
rien qui est impossible il suffit juste
d'adapter par rapport au handicap et ça
passe quoi
la reconstruction et la réinsertion par
le sport sont au cœur des dispositifs
spécifiques mis en place par le
ministère des armées il s'inscrit dans
une approche plus globale et
pluridisciplinaire d'accompagnement des
blessés dans ce cadre les blessés
peuvent participer à des stages annuels
multisport et pour ceux qui souhaitent
aller plus loin participer à des
compétitions nationales internationales
militaires et civils aujourd'hui qui
fonctionne bien
dont on voit les résultats
de manière très probante avec DBC
militaires qui se reconstruisent qui se
resocialise à travers un projet sportif
et qui retrouve une place et surtout une
reconnaissance de l'institution qu'il
recherchait avant tout et lui retrouve
évidemment le sourire et un hépoquement
personnel ce qui est quand même
l'objectif de l'ensemble de ce
dispositif
dans la dynamique de l'obtention des
Jeux Olympiques et par olympiques de
Paris 2024 le Centre national des sports
de la Défense organisera dès que le
calendrier le permettra les Heroes
military games
cet événement sportif devrait regrouper
des militaires valides et blessés de 32
nations différentes
quittons le parquet du gymnase pour la
pelouse du stade du 21e régiment
d'infanterie de marine de Fréjus sur le
terrain s'entraîne l'équipe de France
militaire de rugby
composé de soldats issus des trois
armées et de gendarmes l'équipe prépare
une rencontre exceptionnelle en amont du
tournoi des 6 nations un match
d'entraînement contre le 15 de France
parmi eux le sergent-chef Tom la semaine
il travaille au sein de l'unité de
soutien de l'infrastructure de la
défense des carrivent le week-end une
chose ses crampons pour jouer au rugby
top 14 c'est un rêve quoi c'est vraiment
c'est l'histoire on les regarde tous les
week-ends à la télé et là pour jouer
contre justement c'est
enfin moi j'en reste sans moi c'est
vraiment génial pour moi c'est
génial de faire son métier et de pouvoir
jouer aussi au rugby à côté donc c'est
vraiment sur mon top quoi faire pour moi
je pouvais pas je pouvais pas
c'est un rêve de gosse c'est un rêve de
rugbyman que vous allez vivre dans une
minute faites-en un rêve exceptionnel
[Musique]
fin du match pas de vainqueur ni de
perdants
l'objectif était d'entraîner le 15 de
France à leur futur oppositions
donc voilà franchement il est au top et
puis c'est encore plus de
nous on avait à cœur de pas passer pour
des peintres contre vous donc toute
l'année on est au service de la France
et puis là on était au service du 15 de
France donc on espère que vous allez
nous régaler pour ce tournoi et puis bon
courage à vous vraiment
[Applaudissements]
on a bien senti qu'il était aussi mais
ils ont rien lâché c'est toujours en
train de se replacer de repartir à
l'attaque même quand il y avait des
tours mauvais il lâché rien en défense
il venait se replacer donc voilà ça
montre un petit peu l'esprit des
militaires et franchement comme je vous
ai dit c'était hyper important pour nous
et on a vraiment pas été déçu
athlétisme équitation les armées
possèdent 22 équipes tout au long de
l'année elle participe à de nombreuses
compétitions sportives nationales et
internationales autant d'échange qui
consolide le lien armé nation et
favorise les relations avec les armes
étrangères et l'échange de valeur
commune
du sport d'élite militaire au sport de
haut niveau il n'y a qu'un pas avec
l'armée de champion la défense est la
première contributrice du sport de haut
niveau français environ 115 sportifs de
haut niveau dont 15 en situation de
handicap composent cette armée
ces athlètes sont des modèles pour
promouvoir en interne la pratique du
sport ils font aussi rayonner les armées
et ses valeurs dans la société
d'ailleurs en septembre 2019 dans
l'optique des Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques 2024 la ministre des
Armées Florence Parly la ministre des
Sports Roxana maracinéanu et la
secrétaire d'État auprès du Premier
ministre chargé des personnes
handicapées Sophie Cluzel ont signé un
protocole interministériel pour
favoriser des actions communes en faveur
du sport de haut niveau
plus important des fédérations dans
l'encadrement de nos sportsidaux niveau
mais également dans la mutualisation des
stages sportifs avec les équipes de
France militaire et puis la
participation de jeunes sportifs à des
compétitions militaires dans le cadre de
contrats réserve
depuis la mise en place du sport de haut
niveau en 2003 les athlètes militaires
ont remporté 77 médailles olympiques et
paralympique dont 31 en or
parmi eux Carol zaï cette championne de
France sur 100 m est aujourd'hui aussi
militaire au sein de l'armée de terre
si j'ai toujours aimé courir plus vite
que les garçons donc au départ c'était
plus un loisir et ensuite mon ancien
prof de sport à entamé des démarches
pour que je puisse m'inscrire en club et
ça m'a permis de faire des compétitions
au niveau régional et national j'ai
voulu intégrer l'armée de champion parce
que je trouvais qu'il y avait pas mal de
similitudes entre l'athlétisme de haut
niveau et l'armée à savoir la discipline
l'engagement et la rigueur dans ce qu'on
fait le soutien des armées a été un
véritable déclic pour Carole il lui a
permis de se concentrer sur sa
discipline et de renforcer
considérablement sa préparation physique
pour aborder les compétitions dans les
meilleures conditions sans se concrétise
sur le plan financier on va dire parce
que jusque là je m'entraînais mais
j'étais pas complètement sereine parce
que je n'avais que mon sponsor le fait
d'être accompagné en plus par l'armée de
champion ça me permet de peaufiner ma
préparation sur d'autres secteurs par
exemple des séances de cryothérapie que
je pouvais pas faire jusqu'à maintenant
je me sens vraiment libre dans ma tête
donc ça fait que je prends beaucoup plus
de plaisir à entraîner et ça fait que je
me pose pas de questions en étant
militaire je sais que je me dois d'être
un exemple pour les autres qui sont là
et surtout de faire en sorte que ce
dépassement de soi ça pique également
dans ma pratique
[Applaudissements]
en 2016 aux Jeux olympiques d'été de Rio
la délégation française comptait 37
membres de l'armée de champion à eux
seuls ils ont remporté 30% des médailles
tricolores
Enzo le fort est l'un de ses médailles
ce caporal de l'armée de l'air est un
redoutable combattant champion du monde
de forêt il est également le parrain
d'un escadron de chasse à Saint-Dizier
[Musique]
l'escrime j'ai commencé en 1996 lorsque
je vis le rafler celle qui a gagné les
Jeux Olympiques à l'époque j'avais 5 ans
et quand on a 5 ans on aime bien jouer
avec avec des bâtons avec ses copains
moi j'ai voulu jouer avec des fleurés
c'est pour ça que j'ai commencé
l'escrime est un sport amateur on gagne
pas d'argent même quand on fait les Jeux
Olympiques les championnats du monde des
championnats d'Europe donc c'est l'armée
qui m'a proposé de m'enrôler pour
épouser les valeurs de l'armée à savoir
défendre les intérêts de la France à
l'international donc ce sont des valeurs
que les sportifs ont de communes avec
les militaires ça apporte une stabilité
financière au quotidien qui me permet de
me focaliser uniquement sur sur ma
performance
militaire du coup ce sont des
rassemblements entre sportifs mais
encadrés par des militaires d'actifs et
on est amené à découvrir plein de choses
donc j'ai eu du couvert le combat
rapprocher le tueur j'ai appris à tirer
l'escrime est un sport de combat
s'asseoir qui décide beaucoup de
tactiques et de stratégies donc on peut
faire le parallèle après on va pas se
leurrer l'escrime si je prends une
touche il n'y a pas de risque pour ma
vie donc il faut il faut bien sûr
nuancer les militaires d'actifs vont
prendre beaucoup plus de risques que
nous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
militaires formentation physique et
mentale partiront effectuer leur mission
sur les théâtres d'opération
si la crise sanitaire liée au
coronavirus le permet nos sportifs de
haut niveau leur envoieront le pas pour
participer à des compétitions dans le
monde entier chacun défendra ainsi à sa
manière les couleurs de la France
[Musique]